[MUSIC]
The work I've done over the last 30
years since I left the GSB has been
very interesting intersection of
business and technology and
creativity.
It's only after I left the business
school that I came to enjoy working
with technology and
doing cool things with it.
When I graduated, there was a huge
recession and I kind of decided to
go the entrepreneurial route.
Did when startup
doing control systems or
focus was on doing large concerts.
We had clients the Grateful Dead
actually.
So I graduated from Stanford and
a year later I was on tour with a
Grateful Dead living in a tour bus.
It really helped me learn how
the product work how the industry
works, learn the customers and
it was incredibly educational for
my six weeks of concert touring
being a roadie.
We sold that company and then saw
that video that I was really
inspired by these professors flying
fleets of drones, information and
then I thought, wow, that'd be
really cool to do an entertainment.
So I found a group of
young robotics engineers and
we joined forces, we spent three
years developing the technology and
then have been flying shows for
the last two years.
We make drones and the software
needed to have them all perform
in a coordinated manner, to do all
the interesting things in the sky.
Drones can make almost anything
in the sky,
they are 3D repositionable pixels.
And so we are developing an entire
system, both hardware and software
that makes it easy to deploy these
drones and have them do
what our clients want them to do.
So entrepreneurial courses
at Stanford gave me a really solid
grounding in terms of how to think
about business opportunities.
What's needed to get in place in
order to be successful how
to think long term how to
think strategically.
Many of these lessons hold true
today and are really important as
you're figuring out how to grow
a business into something really
successful and lasting.
Where things have shifted for
me lately is normally I was behind
the scenes.
And because we are exploring new
territory with drones and
pushing the envelope we've been
much more the creatives ourselves.
That's why we just went
on America's Got Talent and it was
a really kind of crazy situation.
Because I never really envisioned
myself being on stage but
there I was, and we put on this
really awesome performance.
And it was different and
unusual to actually sort of be in
front of the camera and
be the talent and to be showcasing
the work that we've been working so
hard on over the last five years.
[MUSIC]
So one of the things that they
always talked about at Stanford
during In the entrepreneurship
classes is that there is no single
path.
And that entrepreneurs come from
all walks of life and
there are opportunities everywhere
and I think I have lived that 100%.
My name is Nils Thorjussen I'm
the CEO of Verge Aero.